the left can harm people just as much uh
as the right if they go
very very deep into it you might be in a
cult too
if you don't know the signs and and i do
believe democrats most especially
are in a deep cult rose mcgowan
who is this actress she was very central
to the
metoo movement rose went on
fox news and came out and said that the
the democratic party is a replacement
church it's like a cult as some of you
know
some of you don't know if you've heard
my name or read anything on me in the
media
i grew up in a cult and it was a very
famous cult
called children of god and it gave me a
superpower
it gave me the ability to see the
control
and the propaganda machine especially in
the us
for what it is and how it harms people
and how the left can harm people just as
much
uh as the right if they go very very
deep into it
and ignore all other aspects of kind of
reality in a way
and and that you're serving a master
that might not be serving you and i
always say i come
in peace i am not here to make people
feel bad about their political choices
but i am here to say
that you might be in a cult too if you
don't know the signs and and i do
believe democrats most especially
are in a deep cult that they really
don't
and know about and aren't really aware
of and
i leave the republicans alone more
because i do
respect people more that are like this
is what we are
this is what we're about this is what
we're against
what she's saying here is not merely
that the democrats are a cult
i think that's true largely but that
sounds like a
relatively more shallow political hit
right that's just yeah you're in a cult
you're okay fine
but she's taking this further and making
a very insightful point here
she said at least for the republicans
who are in a cult
and you know culture and cult have a lot
to do with one another
people call all sorts of religions cult
but at least
for the republicans at least for the
people on the right they know that
they're in it
plenty of people call the catholic
church a cult i would call it the one
true church
i know that i'm in it i know i'm coming
i'm right out with you here i say i yes
i am in the catholic church which
believes certain things and doesn't
believe other things
maybe you're a methodist people call
that a cult well you're
very few people are methodists still
these days but let's say that you are
you know that you're in it you use that
term
people on the left don't know that
they're in it
they don't know that when they say that
a baby is not a baby
that a baby is a baby if the mother
wants the baby but a baby is not a baby
if the mother doesn't want a baby
that they are making a very
bizarre religious claim about personhood
and insolent and human dignity
they don't realize that when they say
that a man who believes that he is a
woman
is really a woman that they are making a
religious claim
called gnostic dualism in that
particular case
they don't they're not aware of that
they don't they don't possess the
language
to understand that they don't have the
sort of
philosophical or theological education
to make sense of that
and what rose mcgowan here is saying is
this is true even beyond these
most obviously philosophical and
theological questions this is true just
in the structure of the democratic party
people don't know that they're in the
cult you know one
two most famous things about cults what
are they
the two things you can always expect
from a cult
sex scandal financial scandal right this
is true of all human institutions
we were talking about the catholic
church before catholic church has faced
both of these sorts of things
sex scandal and financial scandal people
try to pretend that the catholic church
is the only group that's ever faced this
of course for those those who have
actually looked into the numbers
public school teachers are much more
likely to sexually abuse
children than members of the catholic
clergy
right the catholics in many ways were
singled out for this but this is true
throughout religious groups and it's
true certainly far more so in the
secular society
but financial scandals too there were
there was that great documentary on the
waco siege
and this was it was a it was a docudrama
rather
and you know it's a kind of
fictionalized account of this
and there's a great line in it where the
fbi interrogator and
and uh negotiation guy is talking to the
people in the house and he said
hey you ever find it weird how all these
prophets of god always seem to
have sex with all the women yeah isn't
that kind of strange how they
god is always telling them to have sex
with all the women in that bizarre
so you see this especially in cults lots
of sex scandals but
more so even lots of financial scandals
hey before you go you can ring my bell
l l ring my bell ring that bell you have
to that way you'll get notifications
like subscribe you know that our
overlords
in the big tech sector don't they're not
the
they're not the biggest fans of the show
okay so if you want to get notifications
you've got to make sure that you go out
and ask them ring that bell see you next
[Music]
time
[Music]
you